how's it going ready buddy we're
teleporting I'm [ __ ] nowhere Oh
welcome back to this greatest game ever
made that has really nice man but I
think that's actually a correct
statement not even gonna lie okay so
we're blowing this [ __ ] up I don't even
know why the story in this game is so
fun it changes like every five minutes I
can take out since then we'll save row
then we'll get a good thing last what
good dammit take out sinister then we'll
save Road what [ __ ]
but first what's a from then we'll
motorboat her tits
you got a main gotta have her her
priorities straight that sounded great
remember to edit that one out here
really
yes this is the real surreal Senate kill
him stealthily you'll die for real this
time
we'll really extra quiet no shooting
throwing grenades or funny business they
better not mess with something alert the
guards they get it and we get it are
they talking about us yeah yeah shut up
I know what I'm gonna win like bad dog
Fox my dog farts not silent but they are
deadly I got a lot of time later you
look at that beautiful Hey oh what's
that
what you're beautiful now stop it you're
making me blush that's why I'm tan now
it all makes sense okay Shh check out
sinister and he's hello how he walks me
stealth okay how does that more quiet
them what I did that's a great point
we're just kind of help people
hammers time a time oh you better self
up cuz I need a man and then I don't
need a man I will always remember Albert
I was cherished whatever we had here are
special five seconds I'm I'm gonna get
you how is that a stealth ship that's
anything whoa these curtains are
beautiful and it's done yeah fact is my
golf swing in a world what anyone would
dip execute sinner press spacebar yes or
be no night yeah okay
why not because you offered me a choice
wait shouldn't bad be a quest what
okay what's good are you almost done I
can't choose I love all music right now
this conversation going
nobody cares that's nuts
wherever I have a canister and beat the
game and you're spending time talking to
him who am I talking to anyway did you
bros get the [ __ ] out of my gam brows
I'm sorry you can be in there I'm sorry
I do care don't they do it well they'd
be nice loser written all over it kind
of has whatever sure yeah I'll end up
with your front door put their finger in
you but what if I like it'd kill
sinister or bees might want to meet up
at the mall at 2:00 sorry I'll be busy
what are you doing is this overly
attached girlfriend my hair then have
glance with someone else okay I don't
think that's a good idea why not I just
found your info online you're hot I
thank you if Sanne creeped me out I'm
he's married
[ __ ] is that a minor my wife she has a
wife
you're kidding right damn I think he is
coming over uh-oh are you still there oh
no oh no okay here we go
or wearing hats for that nice beautiful
absolutely beautiful
hurt I want to work it's twerking and
Twitter and Facebook just battle spoiler
alert I killed him yeah recommend
playing an extreme of course Wolverine
pose first I thought you only killed
what another god damn it yeah don't
believe me check the label on his back
Chyna
the other label who would about to
rescue road by the way she's about to be
tortured and killed by blockbusters oh
yeah we did forget about it just checked
into arena I want to use twerked
it sounds awesome I love arenas it games
it's like my favorite type of gameplay
honestly oh hello Misha that did no
damage at all what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this guy there we go okay by these
old business
maybe oh oh [ __ ]
riskier Oh what is he gonna do it oh
yeah we had the bomb that was necessary
what a player he needs to absorb our
healing factor through skin contact
broke there's no time to explain we get
a suck face like there's no tomorrow
oh I'll be gentle in time baby you're
sucking too much of my oh yeah ooh girls
are as far as ever
ma'am I'm a little turned on right now
what why why why well it was we have
groups attached to it why what's the
point that doesn't make any sense at all
oh hey she's pretty bad out
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] are you doggy
no action okay hi no guts no gory
[Laughter]
ah no my dad gets in there okay well
it's just quality gameplay as always
okay not in the but what is the fun way
this game is [ __ ] up are you [ __ ]
there
I like how the guy and the name is like
what is going on
this guy can't really move oh now again
oh [ __ ] look at our house
Oh was I supposed to die
[Music]
hey babe good to see you
everyone wait that is a girl that's kind
of sad like a sad love story or whatever
this game so weird what am I doing here
what are you doing here why are we dance
why not
and now we're together as always on time
is about it I need you to do something
for me
yes David sugar skull mr. sinister is
exhuming mutant corpses and harvesting
their DNA okay sounds heavy the spirits
of those mutants still linger here
yearning to stop him I cannot claim them
hey wait my late night rats bra
you want me to free their souls my pony
muffin my bro yeah like a Deadpool
why is my pony bribe pull yourself
together
ah Jane okay thanks how the hell does I
dance on a tree we're sending you down
the tracks that lever
we forgot to pull out
okay hey guys a whole new Plateau
[Music]
why use one when we can use 3 1 million
genius
you'll break the shipping for the level
a cow yeah
maybe we should have listened to that
goddammit oh well we're trying
and that's how you tell people they
embrace all right let's find a [ __ ]
lever ah
III okay
here we are we get deadpool coins
awesome i [ __ ] loaded every time like
it has a great can like consistency
means jokes like i thought never gonna
run out of good jokes but it still
[ __ ] awesome mine crimes my [ __ ] Oh
Indiana Jones get out of my game how can
he not love this game I don't understand
get out of here why do i mi shooting
them anyway they're just doing awesome
poses ah [ __ ] it
syllabi hi
oh shut up and get down here okay try
this right Sinister's clones are here my
calculation shows is to be a major
confluence of temporal flux I haven't
caught yeah oh yeah just play along
hey you have no idea how it work your
role is in stopping sinister I do I just
don't care alright I'm gonna have to end
this episode here he was enjoyed
watching leave a like if you did help me
out a lot hit subscribe to become a
breath today I'm gonna be sad when this
one is over at honestly anyway sound
somebody sorry to interrupt the outro
but I just want to let you bros know
that I've recorded a show called
PewDiePie and Friends and it's over at
Polaris so go there and subscribe and
check out our first episode it's pretty
awesome Jesse Cox Dodger and cinnamon
toast ken is in it and it's it's pretty
funny so yeah click the links in
description or screen and I'll see you
there